the Dubai International Holy Quran award
on 20th
Ramadan now my pleasure to ask Dr Zak n
to proceed to the stage so please you
are welcome Dr Zakir n conferred the
Dubai International Holy Quran award for
Islamic personality of the Year 1434
H it's an honor hon and a
pleasure for me to be invited by the
Holy Quran award
Dubai the Dubai International Holy Quran
award committee under the patronage of
Sheikh Muhammad bin Rashid Al
makum the vice president of UAE and
ruler of Dubai has appreciated Dr Zakir
Nike's service to Islam and will be
conferring him with the Dubai
International Holy Quran award for
Islamic personality of the year 1934 H
at a ceremony at the Dubai Chamber of
Commerce Dubai UAE on 20th Ramadan 1434
H that is Monday 29 July 2013 at 9:30
p.m. Dr Zakir Nik Islamic personality of
the year
[Music]